[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم الحديث عن العالم
العربي والعلاقات العربيه العربيه دائما
مطروح وفي الغالب مطروح بشكل سلبي لان هذه
العلاقات لا ترقى الى ما تتمناه الشعوب
العربيه لكن العلاقات العربيه العربيه
والتنسيق فيما بينها بيطرح بالحاح شديد
حين تواجه الدول العربيه بازمات كبيره
وضخمه مثل تلك التي تواجهها الدول العربيه
الان من خلال العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه
ما هي حقيقه المواقف العربيه مما يجري
هناك ماذا يجب ان تكون عليه المواقف
العربيه المبررات والدوافع اللي بتقف وراء
الموا مواقف الح الحكومات العربيه
المختلفه مما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله هذا هو موضوع حديثي اليوم مع
استاذي الدكتور احمد يوسف احمد استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه الذي كان مهتما لسنوات
طويله بما يعرف لدى الاكاديميين بالنظام
العربي يعني العلاقات العربيه العربيه
مساء الخير مع الدكتور مساء النور يا
استاذ سيد اسال حضرتك السؤال بشكل مباشر
ومنه بقى حضرتك تفهمنا اللي بيحصل الناس
بي قالوا كده بيحاولوا يفهموا طبعا
كالعاده الشعور العام لدى الناس وهذا لا
يخفى على احد ولا يخفى حتى على رؤساء
وملوك الدول العربيه ان هناك
احباطا من غالبيه
من مواطنين يعني من رد الفعل العربي على
تجاوزات وعدوان اسرائيل على غزه ف من
النقطه ديت هل حضرتك بتشارك انه هناك عجز
ولا هذا مبالغ فيه واسبابه
شكرا يا استاذ سيد وطبعا من جهه ان هناك
عجزا ا بالتاكيد
هناك عجز في تبني موقف عربي مشترك يعني
بعض المواقف العربيه جيده ولكن هناك مواقف
عربيه اخرى تختلف معها والمحصله انه لا
يوجد موقف عربي موحد تجاه هذه الاحداث
وهذا الحقيقه يدفعني الى الحديث عن تطور
مهم
ا مر به النظام العربي ووصل به الى حالته
الراهنه النظام العربي منذ نشاته يعرف
ظاهره الصراعات البينيه اي الصراعات بين
وحداته المختلفه الدول العربيه فيما بينها
الدول العربيه فيما بينها ولدينا نماذج
شهيره في او
مختلفه الخلاف المغربي الجزائري الخلاف
السعودي اليمني العراقي الكويتي السوري
العراقي اليمني الجنوبي اليمني الشمالي
الى اخر هذه الامور في اوقات مختلفه وفي
قضايا مختلفه
ولكن النظام العربي في مرحله المد القومي
ومرحله التماسك كان يتميز بانه عندما يحدث
خطر خارجي كانت الدول العربيه تتوحد في
مواجهه هذا الخطر رغم الخلافات فيما بينها
يعني على سبيل المثال عندما بدا ان
اسرائيل على وشك تنفيذ مشروعاتها لتحويل
مجرى نهر الاردن في مطلع ستينات
العقد الماضي وكان ذلك التوقيت
شديد الكثافه
في تفاعلاته الصراعيه الكلام ده كان سنه
1963 كان في مواجهه مغربيه جزائريه مسلحه
بسبب خلافات حدوديه كان في مواجهه مصريه ا
سعوديه تضمنت ابعادا مسلحه بسبب الخلاف
حول الموقف من ثوره 26 سبتمبر في اليمن
مصر كانت تؤيد الجمهوريين بقوات موجوده
على ض اليمن والسعوديه كانت تؤيد الملكيين
ووصل الامر في بعض الاحيان انه القوات
الجويه المصريه قصفت قواعد
الملكيين اليمنيين على الحدود المصريه
السعوديه ف الصدام كان صداما حقيقيا وقطعت
العلاقات سوريا قط علاقات مع السعوديه اه
السعوديه قطعت علاقتها مع مصر سوريا البعث
والعراق البعث كان في اسوا حاله من
العلاقات فيما بينهما ازمات العلاقات
ال العراقيه الكويتيه الكويت استقلت سنه
و 61 وقبيل استقلالها طالب عبد الكريم
قاسم رئيس وزراء العراق انذاك بان تعود
الكويت الى ما يعتبره حضن الدوله الام فما
اريد قوله ان في مطلع الستينات كان هناك
عنقود متكامل من الصراعات العربيه في
المشرق والمغرب ومع ذلك بمجرد ان دع
الرئيس عبد الناصر لقمه عربيه تواجه مخاطر
مشروع تحويل مجرى نهر الاردن الاسرائيلي
التمت القمه العربيه في القاهره بعد
يعني حوالي ثلاث اسابيع من دعوه الرئيس
عبد الناصر ولم يتغيب عنها احد القائد
العربي الوحيد الذي تغيب عنها كان الملك
ادريس السنوسي ملك ليبيا وارسل ولي عهده
وهذه القمه اجتمعت ودفعت بالصراعات
العربيه الى الخلف واتفقت على مواجهه
للمشروعات الاسرائيليه واتفقت على قياده
عربيه مشتركه ووالى اخره ما اريد قوله ان
الخلافات العربيه لم تمنع من بلوره موقف
مشترك تجاه ا قضيه من ا الق قضايا وتكرر
هذا بانتظام عندما وقع عدوان 67 كانت
العلاقات المصريه السعوديه في اسوا
مراحلها ومع
ذلك جاء الملك فيصل الى قمه الخرطوم وذهب
عبد النصر الى قمه الخرطوم وتمت تسويه
الخلافات وقدمت السعوديه والكويت والمملكه
الليبيه دعما ماليا لدول المواجهه اذا تم
ايضا في هذه المره تجاوز الخلافات العربيه
من اجل مواجهه العدو المشترك طبعا حرب 73
كانت نموذجا فذا لمعادله الامن
القومي ال عربي لكن بعد ذلك بدات الامور
تهتز قليلا او كثيرا بعد بدايه عمليه
التسويه السياسيه مع اسرائيل ومع ذلك اللي
هي بداتها مصر في 78 في 77 بزياره الرئيس
السادات للقدس ومع ذلك وهذه ملاحظه مهمه
جدا عندما بدا للحظه من اللحظات ان ايران
يمكن ان تحقق نصرا في حربها ضد العراق اذا
بقمه عمان
1987 تجتمع لانه كان نتيجه المعاهده
المصريه الاسرائيليه قررت الدول العربيه
قطع علاقتها الدبلوماسيه مع مصر والتزمت
كلها بهذا القطع عدا الصومال وسلطنه عمان
والسودان فجاءت قمه عمان في
1987 لكي تقرر انه اعاده العلاقات بين مصر
والدول العربيه مساله سياديه لانه قبل ذلك
كانوا يقولون ان العلاقات قطعت بقرار
جماعي ويجب ان تعود بقرار جماعي قالوا لا
الدوله التي تريد اعاده علاقتها تعيدها
وفورا عادت كل الدول العربيه علاقتها مع
مصر ما عدا اعتقد سوريا وليبيا تاخرت حتى
1989 لكن اقصد سنه 87 عادت معظم الدول
العربيه معظم الدول العربيه ولم يبقى سو
لا علشان كان الهدف مواجهه ال ان تكون
الدول العربيه يدا واحده في مواجهه ا
مواجهه ايران مواجهه ايران مواجهه ايران
ايوه هناك حدث فارق حدث في 1990
وهو غزو الكويت لان غز غزو الكويت افسد
معادله الامن العربي لاول مره بياتي تهديد
الامن العربي من الداخل لاول مره ياتي
التهديد من الداخل على نطاق واسع لان حضرك
ذكرت امثله كثيره خلافات كثيره لا تهديد
يعني ايوه يعني بدرجه لا يمكن التسامح معه
يعني مثلا الحاله الجزائريه المغربيه خلاف
حدودي لكن العراق او يعني عراق صدام حسين
والحياه مش عراق صدام حسين وحده لكن كان
هناك انكار لحق دوله الكويت اصلا في ان
تكون دوله وبالتالي هذا التهديد جاء من
الداخل وليس تهديدا خارجيا وبالتالي
المعادله بدات تفسد خاصه وقد كان يعني
انهاء الغزو العراقي مستحيلا بدون تدخل
خارجي واساسا تدخل امريكي ثم يعني حدثت
الطامه الكبرى نتيجه هذه التطورات انه
عندما غزت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
العراق في
2003 بتهم
باطله لم تحرك الدول العربيه ساكنا في
البدايه اتخذت قرارات واعترضت ووالى اخره
لكن عندما وقع الغزو لم يحدث اي شيء لم
يحبر ان الغزو العراقي كان بدايه او اول
محطه يظهر فيها العجز العربي بشكل واضح
جدا عن حمايه الامن القومي العربي بالضبط
يظهر فيها العجز عن بلوره موقف مشترك لانه
يعني لا يخفى ان بعض الدول العربيه لم تكن
حريصه على بقاء نظام صدام حسين بسبب سلوكه
تجاهها
وهكذا هذا هو جذر ما يحدث الان انه الان
نحن في مرحله كل دوله عربيه تنطلق في
سلوكها ليس من المصلحه العربيه المشتركه
ولكن من مصلحتها كما تراها وبالتالي قد
تتوافق بعض الدول العربيه على موقف
معين وتتوافق اخرى على موقف اخر ولا يهتم
فريق ثالث بما يحدث اصلا المهم ان هذا
يترجم الان في انه لا يوجد موقف عربي
مشترك مما يحدث في غزه ناهي عن ان يكون
موقفا فعالا لانه بالتاكيد لو ان هناك
موقفا عربيا مشتركا المسائل تختلف تماما
لنتذكر عندما مثلا قطعت الدول
العربيه المصدره للبترول البترول عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في 73 في 73
ما الذي حدث كانت هناك اوراق الان لا توجد
بايدينا هذه الاوراق لسبب بسيط انه لا
يوجد موقف عربي مشترك لدينا اوراق ولا
ترغب الدول في استخدامها يعني ايه طبعا اه
لانه كل دوله زي ما حك بتقول بتتحرك وفقا
لمصالحها مش من من اطار انه يجب ان ننسق
فيما بيننا يعني مش شايفين ان في مصلحه
للتنسيق فيما بينهم بالضبط وعلى فكره هذا
يعكس ان حاله التكامل في النظام العربي
ضعيفه لانه عمليات الاندماج كالاتحاد
الاوروبي مثلا وهو عمليه اندماج ناجحه
بيبقى مفهوم ضمنا ان الدول الداخله في
عمليه الاندماج هذه سوف تضحي في بعض
المجالات في مقابل ان تحقق مكاسب في
مجالات اخرى هذا المنطق عندنا لم يبدا بعد
هو حتى دخل الاتحاد الاوروبي بس دي قصه
طول شرحها لما وجه بتحدي كبير الخلافات
بينهم واضحه يعني زي الكورونا مثلا زي
الكورونا ومين اللي يجب ان يحصل على
المساعدات ومين ال ا يجب ان يعطي
المساعدات زي زي الحرب الاكرانيه وما قد
يمكن ان يحدث كتدابير الاكر ا طب في
خلافات واضحه ويعني لكن في الوضع العربي
طبعا الوضع اكبر بكثير من الخلافات
الاوروبيه الاوروبيه بس عاوز اقول لحضرتك
على حاجه هل في اجابه قصيره لفكره تصنيف
مواقف الدول العربيه لفئات مما يجري يعني
حضرتك قلت في دول اصلا هو في دول خارج
المعادله يعني خارج المعادله بحكم ظروفهم
انا ماعرفش اذا كان حضرتك توافقني ولا لا
يعني مثلا في الحاله السودانيه هم في حرب
اهليه فبيته لي صعب قوي انه يكون مهتم
كثيرا بما يجري في
الاراضي المحتله الوضع في ليبيا نفس القصه
الوضع في اليمن نفس القصه فعشان انا يعني
انا حابب اسمع من حضرتك مشان انا اتكلم
يعني هل ممكن نصنف تقريبا الجريز او
الفئات المختلفه للدول العربيه مما يجري
هو طبعا انا فقط اريد ان اعلق على انه
يعني افرق بين الاهتمام والمقدره اه لانه
انا اتصور ان الشعب العربي في سوريا
والشعب العربي في السودان والشعب العربي
في ليبيا والشعب العربي في اليمن رغم ان
هذه الدول جميعها تواجه اوضاعا شديده
الخطوره تهدد يعني يعني تهدد وحده الدوله
وتهدد تماسكها الا ان الشعوب لها موقف اخر
وانا هضرب حتى لا اطيل ساضرب مثالا وحيدا
بانتفاضه الشعب الليبي في شرقه وغربه رغم
الانقسام الشديد عندما التقت وزيره
خارجيته السابقه نجلاء المنقوش مع وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي انا شخصيا دهشت يعني
هذا شعب يعيش حاله انقسام بين شرقه وغربه
وصدامات كانت مسلحه في وقت من الاوقات
وحكومه الغرب يعني يعني قد تكون متهمه
بانها اقرب الى التحالف الغربي او شيء من
هذا القبيل المهم انه عندما حدث هذا الحدث
اذا
بالشعب الليلي الليبي في شرق ليبيا وغربها
ينتفض واضطرت اولا احيلت للتحقيق ثم اقيلت
ثم غادرت البلاد فهذا يبين ان الشعوب
العربيه م لانه وبهذه المناس اود ان اقول
انه رغم اننا قد ننتقد ضعف المواقف
العربيه الرسميه الا اننا راينا جميعا
مواقف الشعوب العربيه حتى في دول تطبع مع
اسرائيل تطبيعا كثيفا شفنا حجم المظاهرات
الذي حدث في احدى
هذه الدول فهذا عن الاهتمام لكن عن
المقدره كما تفضلت حضرتك انه هذه الول
تواجه تهديدا مصيريا يعني مهدده بالتفكك
وبالتالي لا تملك القدره اصلا على ان تدلي
بدلوها في هذا الموقف الراهن طيب نعود بقى
الى السؤال مره اخرى ده توضيح مهم يعني
تصنيف الدول العربيه مما يجري هناك تصنيف
مواقف الدول العربيه مما يجري في الاراضي
المحتله هو طبعا هناك دول ذات علاقات قويه
باسرائيل
وا او يعني خلينا نقول علاقات طبيعيه مع
اسرائيل سواء الدول التي توصلت الى هذه
العلاقات لتحرير ارضها كحالت مصر والاردن
او الدول التي في وقت من الاوقات رات ان
مصلحتها او نتيجه لضغوط معينه ان تقيم
علاقات مع اسرائيل كحاله موريتانيا التي
اقامت علاقات مع اسرائيل اعتقد بضغوط
خارجيه شديده لان الشعب الموريتاني ان لم
يكن اكثر الشعوب العربيه عروبه فهو من
اكثرها عروبه ولهذا في اول مناسبه وهي
العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه في 2008 قطعت
العلاقات وصارت صفحه
من
1998 وقطعتها سنت واعيدت قصدي قطعت في اما
2008 او 2009 لا اذكر بالضبط ثم هناك دول
وجدت انه رؤيتها الجديده لمصالحها ان تقيم
علاقات سلميه مع اسرائيل وهي دول
الاتفاقات التي سميت بالاتفاقات
الابراهيميه والمغرب والسودان والسودان بس
السودان لم تفعل يعني السودان بسبب ظروفها
الداخليه اه
يعني يعني ضر الاتفاقات الابراهيميه لاث
دول في الاساس يعني والله هو اللي يعني
جعل الم مسائل تبدو هاجز في السودان هو
الصراع الداخلي فهذه فئه من الول الدول
التي لها علاقات باسرائيل وهناك الدول
التي ليست لها علاقات
ا باسرائيل
والملاحظ انه ليس كلها يتبنى مواقف بالغه
التشدد فالحقيقه انه يعني ما اريد التركيز
عليه ان المهم بالنسبه لي انه لا يوجد
موقف عربي مشترك لانه لو ان هناك موقفا
عربيا مشتركا بالتاكيد كان سيكون اكثر
فاعليه من هذا ونلاحظ طبعا ان هذا ينعكس
على الجامعه العربيه لانها لا تستطيع ان
تتبنى موقفا واحدا لان هناك من يريد تشدد
اكثر وهناك من يريد مرونه اكثر وبهذه
المناسبه يعني اود ان اشير الى ان يعني
قطاعات من الراي العام العربي يعني تمطر
الجامعه العربيه بالانتقاد وال واحيانا
السخريه وما الى هذا وهم لا يدركون ان
الجامعه العربيه ليست الا مراه عاكسه
للواقع العربي يعني ان تحدثنا عن الامانه
العامه للجامعه العربيه هذا جهاز يقوم
بواجباته المتحده بالضبط يقوم بواجباته
خير قيام لكن المشكله انه تنفيذ رؤيه
عربيه مشتركه غائبه اصلا وان تم التوصل
اليها فان تنفيذها مرهون بالدول العربيه
المختلفه فيما بينها لا شك يضعف الموقف
العربي طب دعن يعني علشان برض تبقى النقطه
واضحه لمن يتابعنا هو الخلاف العربي فيما
يتعلق بما يجري هناك يعني مدى جديه الدول
العربيه في اتخاذ مواقف واضحه لرفض ما
يجري في اسرائيل السبب الاساسي في حرص هذه
الدول على علاقتها مع اسرائيل خصوصا الدول
اللي بنت علاقات مع اسرائيل مثلا زي
الامارات وزي البحرين بالنسبه لمصر
والاردن هم متضررين فلازم ياخدوا مواقف
يذهبوا الى ابعد ما يستطيعون فالحديث عن
الاردن ومصر هم متضررين وبالتالي فتشدد
مفهوم يبقى الفئه الاولى اما بسبب حرصها
على العلاقات مع اسرائيل زي ما حضرتك اشرت
منها مثلا الامارات والبحرين او دوله زي
السعوديه كانت قطعت شوطا في يعني وراء
الكواليس في التطبيع المحتمل مع اسرائيل
يعني السبب هو اسرائيل واحد ولا ان
العدوان واقع على فصيل هو صداع في راس
انظمه عربيه حماس بتنتمي حماس كانت
علاقتها متوتره بدول عربيه كثيره وهي
بتنتمي الى جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اللي
هي مصنفه في دول عربيه كثيره ك جماعه خطره
يعني وبعض الدول صنفتها كما جماعه ارهابيه
ام لسبب ثال العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده
مثلا هو انا اريد ان اعلق على الطرح الذي
تفضلت به يا استاذ سيد ان هناك ملاحظه
للانصاف يجب ان تقال ان الدول التي طبعت
مع اسرائيل كانعكاس لرؤيه خاصه لها هذه
تكاد ان تكون جميعها ملتزمه بالمواقف
الدبلوماسيه من القضيه
الفلسطينيه
وبالتالي فموقف لا يختلف كثيرا عن موقف
الدول التي تؤيد
بالدبلوماسيين وهؤلاء لا يطبعون ومع ذلك
فان حصيله المواقف تكاد ان تكون واقعه
واحده لان الكل يتحدث عن سقف دبلوماسي
تصريحات مواقف تمام و بالتالي فال موقف
الجزائر مش مختلف كتير عن موقف ال طبعا
الجزائر لها موقفها الشديد الوضوح لكن
اقصد انه لا يتجاوز السقف الدبلوماسي حتى
الان لا يذهب ابعد من ذلك ادانه فقط يعني
ايوه بالضبط يعني العبارات تشتد كده لكن
كلنا لسنا في الوضع سواء الذين لهم علاقات
مع اسرائيل او الذين ليست لهم علاقات مع
اسرائيل يتحركون في السقف الدبلوماسي ال
سياسي اي لا يتجاوزونه الى اجراءات اكثر
فاعليه في رضع اسرائيل او تهديدها بال
ملاحظتي الثانيه
انه السعوديه كانت تطرح فكره انه نطبع
معكم ولكن في مقابل تنازلات تقدمونها
للقضيه الفلسطينيه انا لم اكن متفائلا بان
حكومه اسرائيل الموجوده حتى الان ستقدم اي
تنازل ذي مغزى هو كلمه تنازل تنازل معناها
البدايه نون ستارتر اصلا يعني مش اعطاء
الحقوق يعني التنازلات معناه انهايه تتفضل
يعني يعني يعني لم يكن عندي امل في ان هذه
الحكومه
المتطرفه غير المسبوقه ستقدم تنازلات ذات
معنى ومع ذلك طوفان الاقصى حدث في توقيت
حاسم بالنسبه لهذه المحاولات واعتقد انه
ستكون له تاثيراته على
هذه العمليه مسار العلاقات او التطبيع
المحتمل بين السعوديه واسرائيل قد يؤثر
عليه يبطئ او يؤجله او يفشله بالضبط
بالضبط وعوده لسؤال حضرتك عما اذا كان
لحماس بالذات يعني يدور في موقف بعض الدول
العربيه على اساس ان بينها وبين حركه
الاخوان المسلمين التي تنتمي اليها حماس
دور في هذه المواقف العربيه يعني اتمنى
الا يكون هذا صحيح لاني ا
اذكر انه في حلقه سابقه يا استاذ سيد فرقت
بين حماس ونحن في مصر هذه المساله شديده
الوضوح فرقت بين حماس كفصيل يحكم غزه وهنا
من الممكن ان نختلف معه في ايديولوجيات في
ممارساته وكف يقاوم يقاوم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهنا يجب ان نكون يدا واحده
ولذلك اتمنى ان يكون هذا هو العنصر او
المعيار الحاكم لمواقف الدول العربيه من
حماس ليس ل بس هذه امنيه لكن انا بتكلم
على مستوى التحليل انه الدول العربيه
مختلفه انا تقديري انه وحضرتك طبعا يعني
ضيف ما تشء ما تشاء انه سبب الخلاف قد
يرجع الى سبب الخلاف العربي من موقف واحد
لادانه اسرائيل بشكل فعال اما لان الطرف
الاساسي الفلسطيني هو حماس التي يعني
تتحفظ عليها على الاقل الكثير من الدول
العربيه او الرغبه في ارضاء اسرائيل
والحفاظ على علاقاتهم معه او الرغبه في
عدم اغضاب الولايات المتحده ف بقطع النظر
عن الامنيات هل تعتقد ان الاسباب الثلاثه
دول صحيحين ام تختلف معهم طبعا هو هذا
وارد وقد تكون وقد يكون هذا
السبب صحيح ولكن لا توجد تصريحات رسميه
تشير الى هذا اني مختلف مع حماس ولذلك
موقفي مما يجري كذا وكذا وكذا فالتحليل
منطقيا يجوز انه انا استنكر تصرفات هذا
الفصيل لان لي موقفا اصليا منه ممكن ولكن
ليست لدينا او ليست لدي على الاقل ادله
على هذا جزيل الشكر معال دكتور الله يخليك